une marée humaine à l'aéroport de Kaboul
à l'origine de ces événements la prise
de pouvoir par les talibans le 15 août
2021 ils sont parvenus aux portes de
Caboul au terme d'une offensive éclair
et se sont emparés de toutes les grandes
villes d'Afghanistan en seulement 10
jours comment les talibans ont-ils pris
si rapidement le pouvoir pourquoi
sont-ils si forts des éléments de
réponse dans FAQ
[Musique]
le mouvement des talibans
a déjà été au pouvoir donc dans les
années 90 et il était historiquement
assis sur une sur une base communautaire
on a souvent dit qu'elle était
ethniquement pachtone
mes chercheurs et directeur du Centre
des études de sécurité de l'IFRI et
comme il le dit il faut comprendre avant
tout d'où viennent les talibans les
talibans ou étudiants en langage tous
sont apparus au début des années 90 dans
le nord du Pakistan il promettent de
rétablir la paix la sécurité et de faire
appliquer leur propre vision austère de
la charia dès 1994 les talibans vont
conquérir peu à peu les différentes
provinces du pays en 1996 il s'empare de
Kaboul la capitale afghane et deux ans
plus tard les talibans contrôle près de
90% de l'Afghanistan
défait très rapidement en 2001 par les
Américains parce qu'il refusaient de
leur livrer Oussama Ben Laden l'état
Liban vont d'abord se replier dans leur
bastions PagesJaunes du sud de
l'Afghanistan pour retrouver leur
influence politique et militaire il
retisse des liens dans les zones rurales
des années 90 qui leur qui ne leur avait
pas permis de conquérir le nord du pays
avec des pachtones qui sont présents
dans le Nord mais mais également des
zones où la majorité et plutôt tadjik
ouzbek et un deuxième facteur qui a joué
c'est que certaines populations pêche
tout n'avaient été formal traité après
2001 et que spontanément et les ont
recherchés auprès des talibans un appui
au-delà des bases partisanes c'est à
Liban nouvelle génération ont trouvé des
moyens pour accroître leur richesse
de dollars d'où vient cet argent il
dispose de sources de revenus variés en
partie illégales
qui sont
par les talibans on peut citer notamment
tout ce qui est de l'ordre de
l'extraction minière qui a
particulièrement voilà gagner en
importance dans les dans les dernières
années notamment au niveau des terres
rares et puis la production et le trafic
de produits stupéfiants notamment
l'opium et l'héroïne qui en est dérivés
et plus récemment les métamphétamines
[Musique]
l'offensive est clair des talibans
rappelle aussi qu'il bénéficie de
soutien notamment de celui du Pakistan
selon les généraux américains les
talibans n'auraient jamais pu renaître
sans l'aide des services secrets
militaires pakistanais ce qui est
étonnant là-dedans c'est pas tellement
la stratégie pakistanaise puisqu'on
comprend pourquoi ils ont soutenu l'État
les bancs une stratégie plus générale
contre l'Inde une stratégie qui a réussi
aujourd'hui mais c'est plutôt
l'aveuglement des États-Unis ont refusé
de voir à quel point le sanctuaire était
l'élément central de résistance d'État
les gants alors que Kaboul venait de aux
mains des talibans voici ce que
déclarait le Premier ministre
pakistanais imrancane
par la suite le mouvement des aliments a
développé appris à diversifier ses
partenaires ou de là du seul Pakistan
pour sortir un petit peu de la forme de
dépendance dans laquelle ils étaient
vis-à-vis de la distance et c'est
tourner évidemment vers les pays du Golf
de Persique avec lesquels déjà des liens
puis c'est notamment vis-à-vis du Qatar
que ça c'est développé à partir au moins
de 2010
mais outre ces éléments les talibans ont
surtout su attendre se préparer puis
frapper au bon moment la progression des
talibans a aussi été aidé par la faible
résistance de l'armée afghane il s'agit
pourtant d'une armée qui a été
modernisée professionnalisée depuis des
années avec le soutien des américains
notamment les contacts très en amont des
années des années avant parfois pour
négocier la reddition des forces armées
et vous avez un deuxième facteur
maintenant qui est que due à l'intense
corruption à l'intérieur de l'armée
afghane très souvent la logistique n'a
pas suivi
[Musique]